you are lucky it wasn't her heart the
heart is not so easily changed I
recommend we remove all magic we've got
some questions for you Cory and Pappy
why would you make Elsa fear her powers
when she was just a little kid we know
you were just trying to help but it
seriously freaked her out and now you're
basically asking her to go on a quest
and use her powers to save the world
that's a huge leap sounds like you know
more than you let on but we'll get to
the bottom of things sooner or later
Queen Elsa Princess Anna and the entire
kingdom of arendelle have gone through
their fair share of changes everyone is
all grown up and ready to go on the
adventure of a lifetime but just how
much will our favorite frozen characters
change keep watching to find out but
don't worry
some people like Olaf never change
Kristoff
when Kristoff and Anna first meet it was
clear as day that the boy was a bit of a
fixer-upper but by the end of the movie
Kristoff had proven that he had what it
takes to date the princess of arendelle
three years will have passed between the
events of frozen one and two so it's
safe to assume that Kristoff is a whole
new person sure he's probably still
goofy rugged and protective but he's
definitely lost his awkward and bossy
edge it's been revealed that Kristoff
will attempt to propose to Anna in
frozen - so it's safe to assume that he
wants to start a family of his own
Kristoff may have changed a lot but he's
still the sweet quirky and unique person
he's always been spen who would Kristoff
be without his faithful reindeer
sidekick spin no one that's who
for a long time span was Christoph's
only friend but that all changed when
they cross paths with Anna
spen is as goofy as his owner and just
as loyal and helpful and impulsive not
much will change first men in frozen -
except for the fact that he now has to
share Kristoff with Anna
Sven will be a little older and wiser
but just as innocent playful and clumsy
princess
anna has come a long way from being the
gullible sheltered princess she used to
be when we first met on a in frozen she
was a wide-eyed stubborn girl with a lot
to prove
anna has one of the best personalities
ever she's witty
hyperactive awkward free-spirited and
everything in between it's hard to
imagine Anna
any other way but she has grown up since
we last saw her ever since Anna found
out the truth about Elsa she's made it a
point to be her sister's keeper I won't
let anything happen to her so we're
hoping she'll find the time to think of
herself in frozen - we think Anna will
let her hair down by the end of the
sequel and maybe even embrace some
towers of her own they run in the family
after all
Hans just when we thought that the Queen
and princess of arendelle had gotten rid
of Hans from the Southern Isles he
creeps right back into the cast list of
rosin - we don't know how big or small
of a role he'll play but we're hoping
his character will walk the path of
redemption sure Hans was cold cool and
calculating and frozen but he had his
reasons
in the end all he wanted was to get away
from his brothers and find a kingdom of
his own unfortunately for him his
charismatic and chivalrous wave got out
powered by his greedy and sociopathic
tendencies if Hans does pop up in frozen
- we hope he'll go from zero to hero
queen Adina not much is known about
clean I do know although we saw her in
the first frozen film she and her
husband Agner disappeared quite quickly
she's described as passive quiet and a
fearful woman but the more we learn
about her the less we think that's true
in the novel of frozen heart we find out
that is Oona is the Peacekeeper of the
family she can call him Agner down when
he loses his temper and she's motherly
beyond belief we'll get to see a lot
more of her in frozen - she'll go from
being a timid character to a brave and
selfless mother she was also a lot less
threatened by Elsa's powers than Agner
was so there's so much more to her than
Disney lets on
the kingdom is not safe
grand pabbie if there's one thing grand
pabbie cares about its protecting his
family and helping others that's why
he's selflessly cured Anna when I Doudna
and Agner came to him in the middle of
the night he wiped on his memories clean
and low-key terrified Elsa of her powers
what he showed her that night made her
lock herself up for years on end now it
looks like grandpa Vee has some
explaining to do instead of warning Alta
about her powers he's encouraging her to
travel north and find out the truth
across the enchanted lands
[Music]
that's a pretty big leap for grand
pabbie
this wise gentle ruler definitely has a
plan up his sleeve
Queen Elsa Elsa has got to be the most
misunderstood person in arendelle but we
think that Elsa will finally start
coming out of her shell in frozen -
she's learned to let people in and
accept help she doesn't have to do
everything alone
she used to be emotionally unavailable
but she did this out of fear of hurting
the people she loves by the end of
frozen - Elsa will have transformed into
the best version of herself and that's a
wrap tell us who your favorite frozen
character is in the comments down below
for more videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows subscribe to the
things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
thanks for watching
[Music]